[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver ici
depuis bruxelles depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
nous allons ouvrir ensemble les portes
de l'europe
et voici le programme l'union européenne
protège t elle suffisamment les
populations des risques aux industriels
l'utilisation et la production de
produits chimiques sont elles
suffisamment encadré des questions à
nouveau au centre du débat après l
incendie qui a eu lieu en septembre
dernier dans l' usine de lubrizol en
normandie
notre reporter s'est rendue elle en
italie à seveso
avant d'être le nom d'une réglementation
européenne cette ville de lombardie a
été le théâtre d'une catastrophe
industrielle
il y à 45 ans nous ouvrirons le débat
avec nos invités en plateau mais avant
tout ce qu'il ne fallait pas louper dans
l'actualité européenne cette semaine de
la démission du premier ministre maltais
à la tenue du soixante dixième sommet de
l'otan s'est résumé pour vous comme
chaque semaine par aurélie d'afas
est ce déjà un premier coup porté au
green deal l'europe n'atteindra pas ses
objectifs environnementaux pour 2020
selon le rapport de l'agencé européenne
de l'environnement et les tendances
actuelles n'augure rien de bon même si
le continent réduit ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et augmente sa part
d'énergie renouvelable
le taux de progrès actuels ne permettra
pas d'atteindre les objectifs en 2030
ni en 2050 selon lagence alors que la
nouvelle commission européenne vise la
neutralité carbone en 2050
le vice président en charge du pacte
vert frans timmermans reconnaît que cet
objectif nécessitera des centaines de
milliards d'euros d'investissements par
an c'est une première pour angela merkel
elle s'est rendue à auschwitz lors de sa
visite dans l'ancien camp nazi
la chancelière a exprimé sa honte des
crimes barbares commis par les allemands
elle a insisté sur le devoir de mémoire
de l'allemagne mais aussi mis en garde
contre la montée du racisme et la
propagation de la haine
aujourd'hui après helmut schmidt et
helmut kohl elle est seulement la
troisième chef de gouvernement allemand
à se rendre à auschwitz
la première depuis 25 ans
interrogation sur l'indépendance du
système judiciaire soupçons de
corruption au sommet de l'état
la situation à malte inquiète l'union
européenne deux ans après l'assassinât
de la journaliste d'investigation daphné
karura galicia l'enquète pointe vers de
hauts responsables de l'état devant la
pression
le premier ministre a annoncé qu'il
allait démissionner en janvier prochain
joseph muscat est soupçonné d'
interférence dans l' enquête alors que
son propre chef de cabinet est mise en
cause
des parlementaires européens en mission
à malte se sont déclarés inquiets pour
l'intégrité de l'enquète et ont réclamé
un départ immédiat du premier ministre
sommet pour la paix à paris les
dirigeants russes et ukrainiens se sont
rencontrés à l'elysée pour tenter de
relancer le processus de paix en ukraine
cette réunion au format normandie avec
la france et l'allemagne en médiateur
relance des négociations au point mort
depuis trois ans la guerre entre kiev et
les séparatistes pro-russes a déjà fait
plus de 13 mille morts depuis 2014
la tenue de ce sommet marque une avancée
positive même si les divergences sur la
frontière demeure
les dirigeants ont convenu de se
retrouver de nouveau dans quatre mois
ambiance tendue au sommet des 70 ans de
l'alliance atlantique
après la déclaration d' emmanuel macron
début novembre affirmant que l'otan est
en état de mort cérébrale des propos
jugés très insultant par donald rome
mais que le président français assume je
pense que quand quand la glace s'est
constitué faut des brise glaces
ça fait un peu de fracas mais ça crée
une voie de passage
emmanuel macron ainsi obtenu la création
d'un groupe de réflexion visant à mieux
coordonner les positions au sein de
l'otan et réaffirmer son rôle
stratégique
nathalie l'oiseau bienvenue à vous vous
êtes eurodéputée française el arem ici
au groupe renoue et je précise également
que vous êtes président de la
sous-commission sécurité et défense
bonjour nathalie l'oiseau bonjour est ce
que vous pensez comme le président
français emmanuel macron que l'otan est
en état de mort cérébrale le constat
qu'a fait amateur
emmanuel macron c'est un constat partagé
par beaucoup c'est à dire qu'à une crise
profonde dans l'otan
autant c'est une organisation militaire
alors l'aspect militaire fonctionne bien
mais sur le plan politique qui est
l'ennemi quelle est la stratégie quels
sont les objectifs de l'otan
nous vivons un moment où la turquie est
membre de l'otan a lancé une offensive
en syrie sans prévenir personne sans se
coordonner avec personnes contre nos
alliés dans la guerre contre dash est ce
que ça veut dire que l'otan va bien sur
le plan politique évidemment non il
était temps d'arrêter de cacher la
poussière sous le tapis de mettre les
sujets sur la table et c'est ce qui
s'est passé à la réunion de londres
ça a permis d'éviter une espèce de
réunion de routine qui n'aurait servi à
rien vous pensez qu'en fait que c'était
stratégique de la part d' emmanuel
macron il a lui même qualifié ces propos
de wake up call d'allah mouais
et ça a fonctionné d'ailleurs personne
n'a été critiqué le fond de ce qu'il
avait dit certains ont dit c'est vrai
mais il ne fallait pas le dire mais
alors pourquoi réunir des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement pour faire semblant
de dire tout va très bien madame la
marquise quand tout le monde sait qu'il
ya des problèmes de fond ces problèmes
ils ont été abordés à la réunion de
londres
on a arrêté de parler épicerie ça fait
deux ans qu'on entendez parler de la
sécurité de l'europe que sous le vocable
de phares dont utilisé par donald trump
pour savoir qui paye et un peu plus et
qu'ils paient un peu moins là on a parlé
lutte contre le terrorisme on a parlé
situation dans le sahel
on a parlé des menaces qui entourent
l'europe
on a parlé de la russie on a parlé des
vrais sujets et surtout on s'est mis
d'accord pour aller dans une réflexion
de fond dont l'otan a besoin c'est une
vieille dame le temps 70 ans
on peut lui dire tu n'as pas changé
c'est de l'hypocrisie où on peut lui
dire mais toi la page c'est ce qu'a fait
emmanuel macron ces propos ils n'ont pas
été appréciés par tous n'ont ni par les
américains ni par un gala merkel alors
en guerre merkel emmanuel macron c'est
souvent deux idées tout à fait similaire
mais de style tout à fait différent
c'est pas inutile non plus anglais
merkel c'est quelqu'un qui n'avance
quand elle est sûre que tout le monde
est d'accord
parfois ça empêche un peu d'avancé et
bien macron il met les sujets sur la
table
il est même et pas seulement auprès de d
autres chefs d'état et de gouvernement
il aimait auprès des opinions publiques
ce que la démocratie c'est ça quand vous
êtes chef d'état vous n'allez pas faire
aux petits arrangements
derrière des portes fermées avec au
camarade chefs d'état en disant aux
populations vous n'en faites pas tout va
bien vous prenez à témoin les preuves
vous dit on à un sujet on a un problème
on va essayer de le régler c'est du
courage politique parce qu'on n'est
jamais sûr d'y arriver on a bien compris
alors le 70e un sommet de l'otan il
s'est tenu il ya quelques jours
malgré les tensions il ya une
déclaration finale unanime où l'on y
parle du défi chinois et des menaces que
représentent les actions agressives de
la russie visiblement on n'a pas cru à
la parole de vladimir poutine que je
vous propose d'écouter le stand bosnie
chase 3 payet
nous avons exprimé à plusieurs reprises
notre volonté de coopérer avec l'otan
sur des menaces réelles comme le
terrorisme international
les conflits armés locaux et le danger
de la prolifération des armes de
destruction massive
nathalie oiseaux on ne peut pas se fier
à la russie en quoi la russie représente
t elle une menace pour l'union
européenne
alors d'abord la russie l'union
soviétique à l'époque c'était la raison
de la création de l'otan l'otan s'est
créé contre la menace soviétique il faut
s'en souvenir
et aujourd'hui la russie de vladimir
poutine a manifestement une nostalgie
bien mal inspiré cette période
soviétique
on l'a vu l'ukraine l'invasion de la
crimée la guerre dans le donbass
on voit des ingérences souvent toujours
inacceptable et souvent souterraine dans
des processus politiques à l'intérieur
de l'union européenne et une raison
forte d'être vigilants vis-à-vis de la
russie
une fois qu'on a dit ça qu'est ce qu'on
fait on ne fait rien on ne se parle pas
c'est ce qui s'est passé depuis
plusieurs années donné le dialogue avec
la russie
c'est ce qui s'est passé depuis
plusieurs années l'absence de dialogue
est-ce que ça a conduit à des résultats
est-ce que ça améliorer la situation en
ukraine dans tous les conflits gelés que
l'on connaît
dans notre partenariat oriental et même
vis-à-vis des pays de l'union européenne
les plus exposés absolument pas il faut
un dialogue vigilant exigeant si ce
qu'on fait engueuler art merkel et
emmanuel macron à paris dans le sommet
avec la dîmière poutine et le président
ukrainien et russe ont à me jeter avec
de la vigilance mais on peut pas espérer
avancer si on ne parle pas ça n'existe
pas alors justement justement à l'issue
de ce mini sommet entre sur le risque
sur le conflit russo ukrainien
il ya eu quelques déclarations
d'intention autour du processus de paix
une prochaine réunion dans quatre mois
mais le dirigeant ukrainien lui n'a pas
caché sa déception qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir de ce mini sommet je crois que
ce qu'a dit l'un des mieux alinsky c'est
aussi ce qu'on partage c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas encore devant une paix
durable
mais on a repris un processus qui permet
des progrès grâce à la rencontre qui a
eu lieu cette semaine parce que c'est un
art à free armée aux portes de l'union
européenne il faudra confirmer aux
portes de l'union européenne c'est la
non reconnaissance de la souveraineté
d'un état indépendant
donc c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinairement préoccupant le
kremlin crime et le dombass ce qui a
permis la rencontre de cette semaine
c'est poursuivre et si possible jusqu'au
bout les échanges de prisonniers qui
avaient commencé entre russes et
ukrainiens c'est consolider le cessez le
feu c'est comme un progrès considérable
et c'est allé plus loin dans le
désengagement des troupes de part et
d'autre de la ligne de front
nathalie l'oiseau je vous pose la
question tel quel le débat est ce qu'il
se pose en ces termes concernant la
défense et la sécurité
soit c'est l'otan soit c'est une armée
européenne l'europe de la défense
la défense européenne elle n'est pas là
pour remplacer l'otan l'otan c'est de
notre garantie de sécurité collective en
europe
mais l'otan ne peut pas tout quand on
envoie des troupes au sahel la france à
titre bilatéral a bien seul au sahel
elle n'est pas n'est pas assez a
accompagné mais c'est faux de dire
qu'elle est seule parce que c'est
insultant pour les pays européens qui
nous ont accompagnés dans barkan ou dans
l'opération vrai qu'elle ne porte pas la
france ne porte pas le fardeau de
l'union européenne au sein je pense que
l'europe doit être beaucoup plus
présente et je m'y emploie on en parle
beaucoup dans la commission que je
préside
en parler c'est une chose mais c'est
convaincre qu'il faut que notre sécurité
à nous en europe
elle passe par la stabilisation du sahel
si demain on a un califat jihadistes
dans le sahel c'est à dire dans une
région qui est à peu près grande comme
l'europe la sécurité de notre continent
sera en jeu est ce que l'otan est au
sahel
évidemment non est ce que quand on voit
ce qui se passe dans le nord de la syrie
avec des terroristes djihadistes qui
était sous la garde des kurdes et qui
aujourd'hui parfois sont dans la nature
parfois pour être récupéré par bachar
el-assad ou par recep tayyip erdogan est
ce que c'est le temps qui s'en occupe ça
n'est pas le cas est ce que notre
sécurité est en jeu wii
si nous croyons en nous même si nous
voulons décider de notre destin est
plutôt que d'autres décident à notre
place
il faut être capable de peser dans l'eau
des dons pour une europe de la défense
évidemment pour une armée européenne
pour une armée européenne beaucoup dit
ça n'existe pas c'est impossible
nos compatriotes et partout en europe on
nous demande une capacité européenne de
nous défendre
est ce que ça veut dire une armée avec
un commandement unique tout le monde
sous la même bannière derrière le même
drapeau
évidemment on n'en est pas là mais
désarmés
capable d'intervenir ensemble qui savent
planifié réactive qui ont la même
culture stratégique qui sont
interopérables qui se sont entraînés
ensemble qui ont des matériels commun
c'est pour ça qu'il faut le fonds
européen de défense
aujourd'hui vous avez plus de dix sortes
d'avions de combat différent en europe
plus de dix ans de frégate plus de dix
sortes de chars de combat imaginez qu'on
essaye de faire intervenir ensemble les
états européens
ce serait un casse-tête c'est pour ça
qu'il faut consolider une industrie
européenne sera sans doute l'un des
défis de cette nouvelle commission
européenne cette europe de la défense
merci d'être venus à nous à persévérer
éclairage on passe un tout autre sujet
c'était il ya quelques semaines
l'accident industriel à lubrizol a
relancé de nombreuses questions et à
cette occasion nombreux sont ceux qui
ont entendu parler de seveso pour la
première fois avant d'être une directive
européenne c'est une petite ville de
lombardie à 40km de milon qui a été le
théâtre d'une catastrophe industrielle
44 ans après flores sauvages et
retourner là bas et a tenté de savoir si
on en avait tiré tous les
enseignements nécessaires
[Musique]
dans ce bois de chêne aux airs paisibles
deux fosses contiennent les déchets
contaminés issus de l'accident de lusine
de produits chimiques
ic mesa près de seveso après la
catastrophe les autorités rase les
usines et les maisons à proximité sous
terre on a enfoui tous les restes de
l'usiné des maisons avoisinantes avec
tous les souvenirs des habitants et on a
enterré aussi les 80 cm de terre qui ont
été raclés pour décontaminer ce bois
ainsi que le matériel de lusine y
compris le réacteur qui a explosé le 10
juillet 76 ce jour là le réacteur de
lusine est en chauffe une soupape de
sécurité saute pendant 20 minutes
un nuage blanc chargé de dioxyde
hautement toxiques va se propager
alberto a 15 ans il s'en souvient comme
si c'était hier
c'est seulement plusieurs jours plus
tard quand je suis repassé aux abords de
lusine que ça a été la surprise la
surprise car dans toutes les rues des
panneaux étaient apparues avec comme
message interdit de cultiver défense
d'entrer dans les zones contaminées
pendant plusieurs jours les autorités
tentent de minimiser le danger avant de
décider l'évacuation de la population
alberto est forcé de déménager à milan
avec sa famille
c'est là que l'armée avait installé le
barrage à l'entrée de l'usiné
là bas dans les jours qui ont suivi
l'accident
la végétation à brûler les feuilles des
arbres sont devenus jaune brutalement
alors même qu'on était en plein été mais
ce qui nous a le plus inquiété c'était
de voir les animaux qui mouraient le
bilan de la catastrophe est
impressionnant
plus d'un millier d'animaux décimé 77
mille têtes de bétail abattu 358
hectares contaminer les premiers cas de
clairac n'est apparaissent 193 enfants
seront touchés par cette altération de
la peau ce jour là aucun mort n'est à
déplorer mais on craint des effets à
long terme
à l'époque paulo mot carélie un jeune
médecin
il lance une série de prélèvements
sanguins sur les personnes exposées à la
dioxine
les premiers mois après l'accident
on a effectué des prélèvements sanguins
sur plusieurs milliers de personnes et
ensuite on assurer leur suivi pendant
plusieurs années dans une étude qui
récapitule 40 ans de recherches sur les
effets de la dioxine sur la population
de seveso paulo mot car ils y révèlent
une baisse de la fertilité et une hausse
de certains types de cancer après des
années et des années de recherche un
show à la conclusion de cette étude
montrent une légère augmentation des
tumeurs et pato bild
dans la zone hépatobiliaire un an ferme
les vannes et au niveau du système
lymphatique avait à seveso
il n'y a plus d' usine en centre ville
la ville a d'ailleurs donné son nom à
une directive européenne qui encadre la
prévention et la gestion des risques
industriels majeurs
si à seveso on a tiré les leçons du
passé aujourd'hui le maire veut aller de
l'avant
une nouvelle autoroute est en projet
pour favoriser le développement
économique de la commune les travaux
pour la nouvelle autoroute devrait
bientôt commencer
il s'agit d'une autoroute qui passera
sur le tracé de la route actuelle qui
relie milan ameddah en l'agrandissant
car à creuser et déplacé la terre mais
tout est sous contrôle
les dernières analyses nous disent que
la situation mais les militants pour
l'environnement craignent que les
travaux de l'autoroute provoque
l'évaporation de dioxyde ce qui ferait
courir un risque pour la population de
seveso
car plus de 40 ans après la catastrophe
la dioxine est toujours présente dans
les sols
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir françois
alfonsi bonjour vous êtes eurodéputés
français au sein du groupe les verts
christophe kugler eurodéputés français
également mai sous l'étiquette lrm roniu
ici au parlement européen bienvenue à
vous et margot tenga bonjour vous êtes
vous dénoncez également belges et vous
siéger au sein du groupe
la gauche unitaire marque bosingwa est
ce que cette catastrophe industrielle à
seveso est ce qu'on peut dire qu'au
niveau de l'union européenne ça a été le
début d'une prise de conscience
concernant les sites industriels à
risques je pense en partie oui je pense
qu'on est maintenant à la troisième
directive seveso déjà donc on entre
entre-temps trois directives qui vont
dans le bon sens folie à je dirais sont
pas suffisantes je pense on peut en
discuter tout à l'heure mais moi je
constate une certaine schizophrénie
parce que la directive c'est une chose
mais ensuite il faut les contrôles faut
les contrôles préventifs et les
contrôles de suivi maintenant on voit
notamment en france mais aussi dans
d'autres pays que le nombre de contrôles
régresse
donc on a vu par exemple entre 2006 et
2014 une diminution des contrôles sur
ces établissements seveso
c'est un énorme problème parce que si on
contrôle pas savez très bien que dans un
modèle de business basée sur le profit à
l'actionnariat du coup la sécurité
risque d'y passer
christophe kugler ces directives
européennes ces trois directives
européennes ces réseaux en 1982 96 et la
dernière en 2012 elles ont quand même
changé des choses en matière de gestion
et de prévention des risques la maison
tout bouleversé en fait un certaine
prise de conscience européenne de la
nécessité de traiter le risque
industriel est ce qu'il y avait de bien
dès la première directive seveso c'est
qu'elle était évolutive
donc on sait qu'il y aura demain à
seveso 4-1 seveso 5
parce que on doit pouvoir s'adapter au
monde qui évolue au process industriel
qui évolue et donc on va voir cette
possibilité là grâce à ce texte européen
de pouvoir évoluer davantage dans les
prochaines années françois alfonsi en
quoi en la matière c'est une compétence
de l'union et non des états européens
mais parce que
le marché est unique que donc il faut
qu'il y ait des conditions de marché
homogène sur toute l'europe pour
l'ensemble des industriels et pour
éviter justement le dumping sur les
questions de sécurité et il faut une
régulation et la régulation doit être
commune à tous les pays d'europe
d'autant plus qu'on nous connaît
aujourd'hui des pollutions que l'on
ignorait il ya 30 ans par exemple les
particules fines qui ont été la grande
pollution de lubrizol
c'était une matière qui est au début en
seveso 16 ans considérait pas comme un
danger pour la santé publique
il n'y a plus de dix mille sites seveso
dans l'union européenne alors je vais
préciser quand même que la directive les
directives européennes seveso elle donne
des grandes orientations mais c'est un à
charge des états membres de les
transposer dans leur droit interne du
coup est-ce que d'un pays à l'autre
l'interprétation des contraintes des
normes est différente monsieur boateng
art
bien sûr évidemment je vous dis au plus
à des pays qui traînent des bons élèves
clairement clairement je veux dire moi
je vais prendre l'exemple la belgique la
belgique a traîné beaucoup sur la cv aux
3 et puis de voir est ce qu'on va faire
les inspections je parle à des
inspections les inspections de suivi un
jeu ds qu'on va mettre les moyens risque
on voit les organiser ça a été un grand
débat au sein de la belgique tandis que
pour moi ça devrait aller de soi la
question là c'est aussi que chaque état
membre va essayer de jouer sur la
compétitivité de ses entreprises
vous approuvez non c'est à dire qu'il ya
une réalité en fonction du nombre
d'établissements classés ou qui
dépendent de seveso
la france par exemple est le deuxième
thé hyènes allemagne 3000 la france à
1300 l'italie la grande-bretagne il ya
beaucoup de pays qui n'ont que quelques
centaines d'établissements concernés
donc cela s'est moins prioritaire dans
leur adaptation pour eux après la loi
nationale notamment en france apporte
déjà des réponses aux questions que que
vous évoquez le pprt le plan de
protection contre les risques
technologiques empêche organisation
autour de sites seveso par exemple donc
et déjà loi qui est qui et qui est
adapté qu'il faut pour mieux adapté pour
rappel le 26 septembre dernier un
incendie a démarré un sur le site de
lubrizol ans en normandie à côté de
rouen pendant plusieurs heures 5000
tonnes de produits chimiques par dans
une épaisse fumée noire qui va assombrir
un la ville normande le site classé
seveso fabrique des additifs pour
lubrifiants seveso lubrizol 44 ans est
ce qu'on peut comparer mais celle ci si
mais c'est à dire que
cet accident industriel très important
démontre qu'il faut faire plus et
davantage ya un creux mais il ya
certainement eu des accidents tout aussi
graves qui ont été évités heureusement
on a un peu progressé sur licitation
aujourd'hui à bien qu'il ya des failles
et que l'on n'a pas encore trouvé la
façon de prévenir correctement toutes
ces risques et il ya certainement
de difficultés de la transposition des
directives dans les états membres c'est
un problème majeur on sait qu'en france
par exemple la directive sur la
pollution des eaux n'est pas
correctement appliqué parce que il ya
les problèmes des pollutions aux
nitrates en bretagne avec tout l'élevage
existera et nous sommes aux procédures
d'infraction d'ailleurs très très très
largement atteinte donc il faut
s'attendre à cela il faut s'attendre à
ce que les états un sudoku qu'ils ont de
gros enjeux économiques autour d'une
mesure qui doit protéger des populations
et le rôle de l'europe c'est de protéger
les européens
il faut s'attendre à ce que les états
fassent de la résistance et face voilà
le thème inédit donc plus de pression de
la part de l'union européenne
il faut demander aussi aux travailleurs
qui travaillent au jour le jour il faut
leur donner le droit et une protection
suffisante pour qu'ils puissent dénoncer
les problèmes de sécurité qui sont les
premiers à vivre expérimentés et à
pouvoir dénoncer alors on va poursuivre
sur lubrizol car dans les heures et les
jours qui ont suivi l'incendié la
population et certains élus se sont
vivement inquiété le pdg de lusine s'est
alors exprimée pour tenter de rassurer
les riverains on écoute vous présentons
nos excuses à la population qui
s'inquiète mais il n'y a pas de raison
de s'inquiéter des effets sur la santé à
court et long terme après l'incident
dans lequel on brûlait des produits du
brise hall c'est ce que démontrent les
terres sont en effet avec plus de 100000
résultats et nous sommes en faveur de
tests supplémentaires à soulager les
inquiétudes du public et nous finançons
ce programme
christophe grudler il est normal que les
riverains de ces réseaux de sites
classés seveso en l'occurrence la du
brise hall soit inquiet après une telle
catastrophe
mais bien sûr alors je sais comme a
précisé qu'entre seveso lubrizol c'est
quand même deux mondes totalement
différents
si on a comme un impact sur la santé
publique épouvantable à l'époque de chez
de seveso
on peut pas comparer vraiment vraiment
les deux la seule chose qui est
aujourd'hui celle de la difficulté des
populations riveraines d'être informé en
temps réel d'avoir aussi les process de
ya ce qu'on appelle des suivis de sites
des commissions de suivi de sites qui
permettent d'associer les riverains il
ya maintenant des techniques modernes
comme le sms qui peut être pulsé
alors que dans mon cas de catastrophe
mais également l'information des
populations en amont et là les
directives seveso
elles ont agi là dessus sauf que
maintenant avec la menace terroriste
depuis quelques années l'information aux
populations elle est moins contraignante
mais c'est normal
enfin on peut pas non plus à voir sur
internet une liste de tous les produits
dangereux qui sont dans les entreprises
pour avoir une sorte de supermarché pour
les terroristes
il faut aussi garder un peu de confusion
de confidentialité l'étude acquis c'est
que les états et soit informé
dans chaque pays de ce qui se passe
évidemment mais on peut pas donner la
liste comme ça à tout va il faut faire
attention avec ces agressions
terroristes aux six nations parce que
c'étaient d'autres mesures sur laquelle
et il faudra insister au parlement
européen c'est pour obliger les états à
avoir une suite est un devoir de suite
sur un incident beaucoup plus solide
est ce que l'on a observé dans les
premiers temps et même maintenant de
quelques mois dans la sphère lui bezeau
le roi qu'on peut craindre des effets
sanitaires à long terme suite lisa il
faut être moi je suis pas trop d'accord
fab suis pas d'accord du tout même avec
cette cette idée d'avoir plus de
confidentialité
je pense que les gens ont le droit de
savoir et on l'a eue avec les incidents
les accidents mais on l'a eue ce aussi
avec des entreprises qui sont que ce
soit dans le sud de l'italie taranto sur
l'impact que ça sur la santé tant en
belgique aussi au port de gants etc
donc les gens ont le droit de savoir en
premier lieu les terroristes n'ont pas
besoin de cette liste internet pour
savoir où aller chercher les les les
substances toxiques et de sa fille il ya
moyen il contourne et ça on n'a pas
besoin de tout dire mais une folle
information claire et protectrice et
souvent parce que je vois c'est qu'on
veut protéger plus l'entreprise que les
citoyens qui vivent autour et ça c'est
le grand problème film désignation
déquilibre je veux dire les entreprises
elles doivent vivre elle doit
fonctionner elle donne du travail aux
travailleurs les frais des légendes et
ses mots terminé donc les entreprises
doivent vivre elle doit donner du
travail aux travailleurs dans de bonnes
conditions est il du 1er forcément des
préversions de l'environnement notamment
des populations qui sont autour de ces
industries donc pour sallèlois devait
équilibrer
il s'agit pas d'un film en demain on
ferme tout une entreprise classée
surplus d'industrie il ya plus de
travail
snell main en donnant des droits aux
travailleurs et une protection citoyens
qu'on ferme les entreprises les
entreprises aujourd'hui vous le savez
travail pour les actionnaires travail de
plus en plus ils ont des bénéfices
énormes et c'est les travailleurs qui
souffrent et qui sont plus en plus
flexible de plus en plus outre été et ça
c'est effectivement des lois qui sont
votées par des martyrs des traditionnels
vous avez beaucoup de pme galement qui
sont dans la question des émissions
classé seveso tri sont des petites
entreprises familiales à qui on va
mettre des carcan réglementaire
non et c'est vraiment élevé comme ex élu
il peut on désormais temps de mener la
scène réveille aux salariés ah non moi
je m'en prends moi ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'une bonne information pour le
public et qui est une vraie protection
des gens et que l'industrie puisse
tourner dans l'union européenne
voilà c'est tout ça ça va ensemble ces
cieux moi je voudrais qu'on ne revienne
à la cartographie des sites seveso à
l'échelle européenne
est-ce qu'il est encore normal que des
sites classés seveso se trouvent dans ou
à proximité de villes de centres urbains
de bassin de population
françois fillon met des gens c'est un
héritage d'une situation et qui va se
retrouver x les phénomène de
métropolisation pop mécaniquement plus
vous concentrer les populations dans les
espaces urbains
plus vous vous exposez à ce que des
sites qui pouvait apparaître en site
isolé à part avant deviennent
aujourd'hui au coeur de zones habitées a
changé cette saison et donc j'en viens
il faut prévoir que le déplacement de
certaines
activités qui sont en général des
activités d'une créative et qui
permettent d'investir dans la
modernisation des process et peut-être
même dans la réimplantation du sinn
quand elles prennent un caractère trop
impliqué dans le tissu urbain
mais ça ça me semble impossible très
sincèrement à mon avis il me semble pas
faisable ni utile aujourd'hui de fermer
tous les sites seveso qui se trouve près
par contre une protection descente est
suffisante ça c'est réaliste dans
l'immédiat oui on n'a pas parlé de la
catastrophe azf et les magnifiques
hâtives
il ya eu des morts là elle a eu des
conséquences humaines considérables bon
et très clairement il fallait se poser
la question sur une telle activité à
risque dans sa de l'espace urbain et on
pouvait la déplacer celle là c'est pas
une unité qui elle pouvait être déplacée
sans grande difficulté d'où la loi
risque en france suite à un sdf qui a
permis justement de régler une partie de
ces difficultés là mais clairement il
faut il pouvoir se replier derrière les
barreaux mais il faut aller plus loin et
rajouter peut-être de nouvelles normes
environnementales et sanitaires qui on
compte sur vous messieurs puisque vous
êtes tous les trois eurodéputés et vous
siéger au sein de la commission
industrie ici au parlement européen
c'est la fin de cette émission vous
pouvez la voir en replay sur les sites
internet des chaînes parlementaires mais
aussi sur l'antenne de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures européennes
[Musique]